scp-5000 gunshots echo down the concrete
hallway of site-22
screams are the only thing that escape
each room a team of men in all black
combat gear and masks move from one
section of the complex to the next
pietro wilson hides in his office
listening to the cries for mercy of his
colleagues
he shakes uncontrollably with fear who
are they
he thinks why are they killing everyone
and how did they find us
moments earlier pietro wilson had been
in the canteen eating dinner with other
staff members
a group of heavily armed men entered the
room they stood silently surveying the
area
one of the scientists stood up and asked
if they could assist them
that's when the carnage started one of
the masked men raised his rifle and shot
the scientists in the head chaos broke
out as the other mercenaries raised
their weapons and began
firing bullets flew everywhere and
piertro was lucky not to be struck or
trampled as he escaped out the back door
of the cafeteria
he ran to his office slammed the door
shut and hid under his desk
now he sits on the floor with his legs
pulled up to his chest
shaking uncontrollably after a couple of
minutes
he manages to take a deep breath and
slows his heart rate he regains control
of his body
but is still filled with fear and
adrenaline
pietro crawls on his belly to his office
door he reaches up and pulls down on the
handle
there's a slight click as the latch
releases he opens the door
just to crack and peers out into the
hallway the flickering emergency lights
illuminate the corridor for a few
seconds at a time
before plunging it back into darkness
there is no one in sight
but from around the corner flashes of
light from machine gun fire flickers
down the hall
the screams of the workers at site 22
are silenced
pietro takes a deep breath and pushes
the door open further
he crawls out of his office and starts
moving away from the violence
unfortunately to get away from the
mayhem he must go deeper into the bowels
of site-22
the exit is the other way but he is too
scared to head
towards the armed men he stands up and
brushes the dirt from his blue
technician jumpsuit
the lights flicker off the hallway goes
dark he reaches out his hands and comes
into contact with the cool damp wall
he feels his way down the corridor
swimming in darkness
after a few moments the lights flicker
back on pietro looks over his shoulder
to make sure he is still in the clear
standing at the end of the hall is a
soldier dressed in all black with a mask
covering his face
the soldier stands motionless pietro
turns to face the soldier
his eyes open wide his heart races he
can't breathe
the figure doesn't move then the lights
flicker out again
and pietro pushes off the wall and runs
blind in the darkness
he sprints as fast as he can when
suddenly there is a loud crack
and a bullet whizzes by his head he can
feel the wind as it barely misses his
cheek
he continues to run the lights flicker
back on he peers over his shoulder
now there is an entire group of armed
men pursuing him down the hallway
guns raised he turns the corner of the
hallway and proceeds down a set of
stairs further into site-22
at the bottom of the stairway there is a
short corridor with a door at the end of
it
there is nowhere else to go he pulls a
key card out of his pocket and fumbles
it
the card falls to the ground pietro
bends down to pick it up
and as he leans over a bullet whizzes
past where his head had just been
the projectile embeds itself into the
metal door he scoops his key card up off
the ground and shoves it against the
scanner the door unlocks
and he dashes into the room he quickly
turns and shuts the door
it locks automatically the last thing he
sees is the assassins running towards
the door
the lights flicker on in the room where
pietro stands the room has only one door
no windows and no vents it is completely
isolated
in the middle of the room is scp-5000
he knew there was an scp in this room
that was designated scp-5000
but he never knew what it actually was
here he is now
staring at it a strange-looking
mechanical harness hanging in the middle
of the room
suddenly loud banging at the door fills
the room the armed men
are trying to break in it is only a
matter of time before they pry the door
open
with nowhere to go pierce wilson knows
that he is dead
he looks at scp-5000 and shakes his head
what do i have to lose
he says out loud only your life a voice
in his head responds
he walks over to scp-5000 and pulls it
down from where it is hanging
it is heavy on the mechanical suit are
symbols he does not recognize
the only thing he knows about the suit
are rumors he's heard from others who
work at site-22
supposedly it first appeared in a flash
of light in the containment chamber of a
ketter level scp at site-62c
the designation of this ketter was
scp-579
the only other thing that piertro knows
is that everyone at site-62c was
slaughtered when containment was
breached
scp-5000 was found deactivated next to a
pile of bodies
he slips on the harness and as if it has
a life of its own
scp-5000 begins to adjust itself to the
exact dimensions of his body
the suit grows and snakes across his
skin wrapping every appendage in armor
then it begins to tighten pietro wilson
starts to scream as
scp-5000 envelops him the suit
rises up the back of his neck and
encases his entire head
silencing his screams the door to the
room blasts open from a controlled
explosion
as the dust and smoke settles the masked
men enter the room
their flashlights move from side to side
as they search for the elusive
technician who had just entered
there is no one in the room all that is
there is an empty rack in the middle of
the chamber
the men fan out there is no other exit
the room is just a solid square of
concrete they're baffled
where did he go one of them shouts
pietro wilson had blacked out from the
pain of the suit attaching to his body
he comes too still standing in the
middle of the room all around him are
men
in black combat gear they are searching
for him he holds his breath and closes
his eyes
but the gunshots never come he opens one
of his eyes and looks around
why haven't they killed me he thinks he
slowly turns his head as men
walk by him with their guns raised he
hears someone say
where did he go i'm right here he thinks
am i dead
pietro looks down to see that his entire
body is contained with an scp-5000
he lifts his hand and waves it in front
of his face he is still clearly alive
but it seems as if the killers can't see
him he walks up to one of the
mercenaries and waves his hand in front
of a man's face
there is no reaction the suit made me
invisible
he thinks pietro looks at one of the men
to see if he can find out who they are
and why they have killed everyone at the
base on the sleeve of the man's jacket
are the words zeta 19 he's never heard
of zeta 19 before
but they must be part of an organization
that is trying to undermine the scp
foundation
the men continued to search the empty
room clearly confused as to where the
technician went
pietro weaves his way through the group
of men and back out the door he had
entered from
on his way through the wreckage that
used to be a door pietro wilson trips on
some debris
he reaches out to steady himself but he
has fallen he closes his eyes knowing
that as soon as he hits the ground
all the men hunting him will be alerted
by the sound of his fall
but the impact never comes when pietro
opens his eyes it is as if he is
hovering just above the ground
he looks down at his feet the toes of
the suit are firmly planted on the floor
like powerful magnets on iron scp-5000
has prevented his fall
and is holding him in place using the
feet of the suit only
he reaches out his hand and gently
places it on the ground he pushes
himself
up to a standing position he turns to
look back into the room
the men are still in there searching for
him pietro makes his way
back through site 22 he walks by his
office and proceeds towards the exit of
the facility
as he passes the labs and other rooms at
site-22
all he finds is carnage everyone has
been killed
an extra bullet has been placed in each
person's head to make sure
it seems that the only mission these men
were on was to kill
everyone and make sure they stayed dead
he continues towards the exit of site 22
that is guarded by two men
as he approaches the two heavily armed
men pietro makes sure to be as quiet as
possible
this is not a difficult task as the
scp-5000
has given him stealth capabilities he
notices that even his footsteps aren't
giving off any sound
it is almost as if the suit is allowing
him to glide across the floor
he is almost to the exit then he will be
home free
he takes a deep breath turns sideways
and squeezes past the two men guarding
the doorway
just as he is about to leave this
nightmare behind one of the guards turns
unexpectedly
the man's shoulder runs directly into
piertro wilson throwing him off balance
he is knocked into the second guard both
of the men scream
what is that one of them shouts they
begin to raise their guns on the
invisible object that just bumped into
them
it's then that scp-5000 takes over
pietro's body
the suit raises his arm and grabs one of
the men by the throat
with a squeeze the man's larynx is
instantly crushed then the suit twists
slightly and snaps the man's neck
it turns to face the second man even the
black mask the man is wearing can't hide
the look of terror on his face
but piertro has no control over what
scp-5000 is doing
he has never killed before the suit
launches pietro's body into the second
man
pinning him against the wall it then
grabs the top of the mercenary's head
and slams it against the concrete again
and again
and again until the man's screams are
silenced
the suit lets go of the man and his
lifeless body slides to the ground as
pietro backs out
when he regains consciousness he's
outside of site-22 standing on top of
the hill
looking down at the facility below he
looks at his hands
then at the rest of his body he is still
contained with an scp-5000
there is a flash of light and a heads-up
display comes on
he doesn't recognize any of the symbols
but as his eyes move from one area of
the screen to the next
the symbols become highlighted before
his eyes certain symbols begin to
translate into words he can read
one of the symbols now says journal
entry unsure of what else to do
pietro begins recounting what happened
to him at site-22
he makes his way through the desert
towards the nearest scp foundation safe
house
he knows once there he will be able to
reach out to his superiors for help and
further orders
maybe he can even find a way to get
scp-5000 to release him
as he trudges along petra wilson notices
that his brain is telling him he is
thirsty
but the vitals on the suit's heads-up
display say that he is in good health
in fact he is better than good his
vitals are all perfect
the suit seems to be giving him all the
nutrients his body needs
it has even fixed his busted knee that
was injured back in college playing
football
the joint itself has somehow been healed
pietro finally reaches the safe house
and opens the door
it is quiet and dusty it looks as if no
one has been there in years
he walks over to the communication
station and tries to contact the
foundation
but all he gets is static he gives up
and walks over to the tv
he pushes the on button the screen
hisses to life
what he sees causes his jaw to draw the
world
is at war a war between humans
and monsters whatever happened at site
22
also happened at other foundation sites
the scps
have been let loose